2015 on an epic here for video games it
deserves an equally epic year in review
video coming [ __ ] boy lasagna dwyer from
gamespot com and over the next 20
minutes I'm gonna be running through
what ended up being one of the greatest
years in the history of video games
hundreds of games came out this year we
won't get to all of them we will
highlight the best the worst the biggest
talking points and the company's and
legends we sadly left behind okay enough
chitchat let's get to the games this
year like so many others began in
january january has always been a bit of
a quiet time for games everyone's broke
after the holidays and we're all too
busy trying to run off all that turkey
fat before realizing hey we're video
game fans and destined to a life with a
pop belly oh just me i well in any case
we did have a bunch of great games to
play hashtag I darb hit the xbox one and
life is strange began its episodic
journey were more than used to games
coming back from the dead in 2015 was no
different sainte-rose got out of hell
graced us with its angelic presence Grim
Fandango came back from the dead
remastered and dying light added some
interesting player movement mechanics to
the first person on dead shandra febri
started with a fire sale sony sold off
Sony Online Entertainment historic game
site CVG got swallowed into games radar
and joystick was shut down by AOL I used
to work in an AOL call center you know
I'd spend all day taking calls from
people who wasted their money on a
shitty product which is probably with
Sony's hotline was like after the order
came out haha yes yes sir yes I know I
know it's a glorified rail shooter but
how about those HD mustaches Telltale's
Game of Thrones series picked up where
it left off in 2014 with episode 2 the
Lost Lords Ubisoft finally made good and
release the best assassins creed game in
years grow home evolve seem promising
but ultimately the mass-market just
weren't convinced by Turtle Rock's new
take on a symmetric multiplayer
everyone's favorite creepy moon returned
in The Legend of Zelda Majora's Mask 3d
and on the very same day the new
Nintendo 3ds was launched the latest
version of Nintendo's console sported an
upgraded processor more RAM some extra
button
and the ability to scan your face
presumably so Nintendo can catalog all
3ds owners and attempt to cram a wii u
down their throats PC fans enjoyed the
launch of total war attila while mac
fans finally got the sims for the former
a game about breaking down protective
walls to kill the people inside and the
latter a game about building protective
walls to kill the people inside while in
a year full of episodic games Resident
Evil started its own episodic nonsense
with revelations to Mars kicked off here
in downtown San Francisco in the
building behind me the moscone center
with the annual Game Developers
Conference kicked off middle-earth
shadow of Mordor was given the g DC's
best game of 2014 while in the IGF the
game outer walls when the Shamus McNally
grand prize while on the other side of
the bay bridge here in emeryville EA
shut down the headquarters of SimCity
and spore creator Maxis we used to
reside in this building here Sally they
were unable to weather the storm of
SimCity back in 2013 but City Building
fans didn't have to wait long for a new
Pretender 5311 miles west of here in
Finland the new king of city building
games was being born city skylines one
of the most popular pc games of 2015
took all that was great about city
building in SimCity road layout zoning
and transit and applied it to an easy to
learn but vastly expandable simulation
the march started with a bit of a scare
five nights at freddy's at two releases
in 2015 the first number three on March
second and speaking of sequels March
also saw the release of olly olly to
hotline Miami 2 and Mario Party 10 tales
from the borderlands made its first
appearance of 2015 with episode 2 Atlas
mugged we saw new versions of old
friends too with battlefield hardline
DMC definitive edition forces fast and
furious thing and blood-borne a
PlayStation 4 exclusive that evolved the
rough and tumble action of the souls
series there was code named steam scream
ride and March was also a great month
for indie games with the wonderful Orion
the blind forest yet standing axiom
verge and fun to stick shooter
Helldivers this month also saw a
nintendo japan announced a partnership
with japanese mobile developer DNA on a
brand new project a dedicated games
platform with a brand new concept they
were calling the n
will we see it in 2016 not long to wait
now April was a fantastic month for fans
of anthropomorphic bread and shooting
innocent bystanders as gta5 finally came
out on pc and just in case april 14th
wasn't going enough it also saw the
release of mortal kombat x a week later
assassin's creed chronicles china and a
week after that the wonderful kerbal
space program a game that many of us
here gamespot loved over the course of
its early access development was finally
officially released and on that topic
the second and final part of Double
Fine's adventure game broken age was
also finally released while in business
news on live was discontinued andis
assets were sold to Sony while former
Sony executive Phil Harrison left
Microsoft but the biggest news of the
month came from japan in march gamespot
broke a story about the possible rips
between Kajima and Konami and in April
we witness what seemed to be Konami
taking a step back from triple-a game
development silent Hills was cancelled
the company planned to pulled PT from
the PlayStation Store and Konami was
delisted from the New York Stock
Exchange all this mere months before the
launch of the company's biggest release
in half a decade metal gear solid 5 the
phantom pain may gave a super fun
standalone Nazi hunter fenceline the old
blood crowdfunded racer project cars a
remastering of final fantasy 10 and 10
to galactic civilizations 3 how many
friendly deathmatch shooter splatoon and
a critically acclaimed invisible ink in
the long tradition of pre III prep
maiden have that many releases but it
did have a big one the witcher 3 wild
hunt from warsaw-based developers CD
Projekt RED took the world by storm by
creating one of the most engrossing and
fascinating open-world role-playing
games of all time heartfelt stories
models of landscape and a dynamic
narrative combined to create what many
believe to be the best game of 2015 we
certainly did which is why we awarded a
game of the year June is also
traditionally a little shy on game
releases as it's the time of the year
that the industry descends on Los
Angeles for e3 but we did get a couple
of notable releases postal clone hatred
came out everyone got pissed off for a
day and then it disappeared back into
obscurity blizzards MOBA heroes of the
storm was officially launched Bethesda
put out a fallout mobile game Nintendo
launched dr. Mario miracle cure and
discontinued club nintendo in North
America there was devil may cry for
special edition
motogp 15 her story and batman arkham
knight which was promptly pulled on pc
because of substantial technical issues
don't worry we'll be more on that story
later
july was a month defined by the
excitement of returning favorites and
the sadness of the parting legends god
of war 3 hatoful boyfriend The Binding
of Isaac and journey returned on new
platforms while five nights at Freddy's
enjoyed its second release of the year +
+ received the long-awaited sequel f1
and PGA got their annual releases and a
new version of Windows was surprisingly
well received this was also the month
Assassin's Creed co-creator Jade Raymond
returned to triple-a development joining
forces with Amy Hennig on EA's upcoming
Star Wars game but while we enjoyed the
company returning friends and so many
fondly remembered franchises we were
also forced to say goodbye to one of our
industry's most beloved creators on July
eighteenth Nintendo CEO Satoru Iwata
tragically passed away at the age of 55
programmer turned CEO he guided the
direction of Nintendo during good times
and bad a vanguard for innovation he
oversaw the release of two of the most
revolutionary and disruptive consoles of
all time while he had the brain of a
business men on the hands of an inventor
what a son was always quick to make us
understand where exactly his heart light
july also gave us something to smile
about sleeper hit rocket League came out
on pc and for free on playstation
network to take the online multiplayer
world by storm quite simply it's one of
the best games of the year and perhaps
one of the best sports games ever made
another great sleeper hit this year was
until dawn the best David cage game ever
made I wasn't even made by David cage +
August was the same month that Disney
infinity 3.0 k match which expanded the
Disney Universe Edwards into a galaxy
far far away August also saw the launch
of dishonored definitive edition here's
a war Ultimate Edition and madden nfl 16
annual edition rare replay jumped out of
nowhere onto the xbox one while
everybody's gone to the rapture shuffled
slowly towards the PlayStation 4 and we
enjoyed more indie hits in the form of
galaxy volume and trine 3 September
usually marks the start of the q4 rush
when most of the big games come out but
even so September first was a bumper
release for games especially fans of
bearded men grunting in the desert
Avalanche Studios Mad Max was released
to mixed reviews while metal gear solid
5 the phantom pain was heralded as an
instant classic the final chapter in
this incredible franchise stepped into
unfamiliar open-world territory the
result the best stealth game ever made
and a game that you could argue straight
faced as perhaps the best in the
franchise in fact September was a month
for solid sequels for two motorsport six
Pro Evolution 2016 FIFA 16 blood bowl to
Skylanders supercharged and world of
warships there was NHL 16 and the sadly
disappointing Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 5
we played lego dimensions the scary soma
and beloved in the hit undertale the
taken King rounded off a year of
expansion packs which greatly improved
destiny tearaway unfolded made its way
onto the PlayStation 4 lovers in a
dangerous space time skipped over the
PlayStation for coming out on xbox one
and pc while the wii u landed another
hitch super mario maker tatsumi
kimishima was appointed Satoru Iwata
successor at the helm of Nintendo and
Sony reading project Morpheus to the
elegantly simple PlayStation VR
oktober was another fantastic month for
releases with the Nathan Drake election
The Beginner's Guide mushroom 11 down
well Yoshi's woolly world and Just Dance
2016 a bunch of games came out of beta
and had their official releases
including elite dangerous and prison
architect after years of no music games
at all rock band 4 and Guitar Hero live
were released within a week of each
other and telltale launched yet another
episodic franchise with minecraft story
mode halo 5 Guardians did much to make
fans of the series happy an assassin's
creed syndicate certainly impressed a
certain section of the AC fan base while
sadly the legend of zelda triforce
heroes and WWE 2k16 were not so well
received by fans even those however
couldn't compare with the eventual
launch of batman arkham knight on pc the
game relaunched in October is still
crippled with compatibility and
performance issues causing Warner to
throw in the towel completely and start
handing out refunds some good business
went down around this time to Microsoft
bought havoc from Intel presumably to
add more power to declare processing
projects while November kicked off with
a 5.9 billion acquisition of candy crush
developer King digital by mega publisher
Activision and while Activision expanded
Konami were going in the other direction
closing their Los Angeles division
November 10th was easily the craziest
day for new releases in 2015 not only
were steam machines officially launched
we also got the third chapter in
starcraft 2 s long-awaited trilogy a
fantastic sequel to the reboot of Tomb
Raider and 2015's most anticipated game
that nobody knew was coming out in 2015
until halfway through 2015 fallout 4
like my place mostly made of dinner
trays and the rest of the month wasn't
too bad either we got to battle on a
rather realistic-looking forest moon of
Endor star wars battlefront may have
been a little bit on the casual side but
at the very least it looked and sounded
the part we saw Triple A Titan call of
duty dropped by for its annual a cup of
tea with the fast-moving black ops 3
street racing fans enjoyed the return of
need for speed while the yokai watch
Deadpool and a rather lackluster Mario
Tennis ultra smash stranded at the
second last month of the year Christmas
doesn't come until the end of the month
but December first had two wonderfully
explosive gifts co-op shooter Rainbow
six siege and the ridiculously high
flying Just Cause 3 The Game Awards
impressed again this year what a quality
show which evoke the passions of both
gamers and developers alike and it also
enhanced the immediate release of shadow
complex remastered so thanks for that
jet fat princess adventures and nuclear
throne finally arrived the wii u had a
surprise hit in Xenoblade Chronicles X
while the devil's turd that was dropped
around the rest of the world earlier
this year finally plopped down on North
America also minecraft came here for the
Wii U that month two on the final game
of 2015 came out on December 22nd a
personal favorite of mine the
re-released version of hot awful
boyfriend holiday star and that was the
year in video games 2015 a bunch of
multiplayer games battling for our
attention a pair of eights standing open
world role-playing games more massive
sound boxes than any of us will ever
have time to complete and a year where
the PC stood tall above the graphical
limits of its console cousins no matter
what you play it seems there was
something for everyone in 2015 the games
like horizon zero dawn no man's sky
Zelda the division and XCOM 2 mere
months away let's hope next year is
equally as enjoyable happy new year the
c1 2016
you